for any group or organization to
function well it's work principles must
be aligned with its members life
principles I don't mean that they have
to be aligned on everything but I do
mean that they have to be aligned on the
most important things like the mission
they're on and how they will be with
each other if people in an organization
feel that alignment
they will treasure their relationships
and work together harmoniously its
culture will permeate everything they do
if they don't they will work for
different often conflicting goals and
will be confused about how they should
be with each other for that reason it
pays for all organizations companies
governments foundation schools hospitals
and so on to spell out their principles
and values clearly and explicitly and to
operate by them consistently those
principles and values aren't vague
slogans like the customer always comes
first or we should strive to be the best
in our industry but a set of concrete
directives that anyone can understand
get aligned on and carry out as we shift
our attention from life principles to
work principles I will explain how we
went about achieving these alignments at
Bridgewater and how that affected our
results but first I want to explain how
I think about organizations an
organization is a machine consisting of
two major parts culture and people each
influences the other because the people
who make up an organization determine
the kind of culture it has and the
culture of the organization determines
the kinds of people who fit in